[Music]  do you have extra bull lying around  we'll bring it to us gold for gold we'll  take your gold and give you a different  gold instead hi I want to get rid of  this gold chain here's a gold bracelet  great you have gold we have gold we  switch no questions asked I had no idea  that my goal was worth so much other  gold is it gold it's a silver silver  platinum or money and we don't make any  money and we don't have a store  this one's just for the ad and real life  call me and I'll meet you at the Popeyes  on Normandie don't forget your gold go  for the gold but gold for gold get  controlled into the gold folded gold for  gold gold  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  [Applause]  Oh